.
THE S&P 500, A NEW RECORD CLOSE.
THE NASDAQ, 32.
WE ARE LEARNING MORE TONIGHT
ABOUT WEDNESDAY'S RAID.
FORMER NEW YORK MAYOR AND RUDY
GIULIANI.
CORRESPONDENT, DAVID REPORTS
TONIGHT FROM THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN INSISTS HE
WAS NOT BRIEFED IN ADVANCE ON
THE FBI'S PLAN TO RAID FORMER
NEW YORK MAYOR, RUDY GIULIANI'S
HOME.
>> I MADE A POINT I WOULD NOT
INTERFERE IN ANY WAY, ORDER, OR
TRY TO STOP ANY INVESTIGATION
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAD.
>> BUT FBI DIRECTOR, CHRISTOPHER
WRAY WERE WELL AWARE BEFORE
AGENTS MOVED IN, TAKING
CELL PHONES, COMPUTERS, AND
OTHER ELECTRONICS.
FOX NEWS HAS LEARNED THEY WERE
GIVEN A COURTESY HEADS UP BEFORE
IT HAPPENED.
STANDARD PRACTICE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT SAYS THAT
DISCUSSIONS OF A RUDY GIULIANI
RAID BEGAN MONTHS AGO DURING
BILL BARR'S TENURE AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE OFFICIALS DECLINED TO MOVE
FORWARD.
BUT WHEN JOE BIDEN BECAME THE
46TH PRESIDENT, THE
INVESTIGATION PICKED UP STEAM
AND QUICKLY.
>> WHEN YOU'RE PUTTING TOGETHER
AN APPLICATION FOR A SEARCH
WARRANT LIKE THIS, THAT
SOMETHING THAT TAKES AN EXTREME
AMOUNT OF FOCUS, OF EVIDENCE.
YOU NEED TO PERSUADE A FEDERAL
JUDGE TO APPROVE THE SEARCH
WARRANT.
>> MULTIPLE SOURCES TELL
FOX NEWS THE FOCUS OF THE
FEDERAL INVESTIGATION SURROUNDS
YOU TO GIULIANI'S TIES TO
UKRAINE, A COUNTRY WHERE HE MADE
SEVERAL TRIPS AND AN ATTEMPT TO
DIG UP DIRT ON HUNTER BIDEN.
ALSO UNDER FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION.
>> HE CORRECTED UKRAINE AND HE
SOILED WITH THE REPUTATION OF
THE UNITED STATES.
NO ONE IS SAYING THAT HE DID
ANYTHING WRONG EXCEPT FOR RUDY
GIULIANI.
>> NOW THE FORMER NEW YORK
MAYOR AND FEDERAL PROSECUTOR IS
UNDER INVESTIGATION BY THE SAME
OFFICE HE ONCE LED.
THIS MORNING, FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP DEFENDED HIS
FRIEND.
>> IT'S VERY, VERY UNFAIR.
RUDY IS A PATRIOT WHO LOVES THIS
COUNTRY AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR.
>> ON HIS LAST DAY IN OFFICE,
THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP PARDONED
THE SENTENCES OF 144 PEOPLE NOT
ON THE LIST.
LEAVING HIM WIDE OPEN FOR WHAT
IS HAPPENING BEFORE US.
JUST LATE THIS AFTERNOON, RUDY
GIULIANI MADE VERY BRIEF
COMMENTS ON HIS RADIO SHOW
TAKING SHOTS AT THOSE
INVESTIGATING HIM WHILE
PROCLAIMING HIS INNOCENCE.
>> I